I want to talk about a problem in
mathematics called billiards of study
billiards and talk about maybe a couple
of aspects of that these are called
polygonal billiards you have some figure
in the plane maybe it has straight sides
or maybe not you can either think of
this as billiards or you could think of
this as a room where the sides of the
room have a mirror start at a point and
we move in a straight line starting at
the point until we come to the side and
then we bounce off the side with the
angle of reflection equal the angle of
incidence so these two angles are the
same and then we continue till we hit to
another side we bounce off where the
angle of incidence equals the angle
reflection and so forth when you hit
into a corner there's no way of saying
what reflection means and so if you are
a billiard player you maybe think of
this as pocket billiards we could also
think of this as I say is a room with
mirrors and you are moving along maybe a
light source a beam of light comes to a
mirror and then it reflects in the
mirror and continues on in a straight
line and so forth and these things go
forever like if they hit a corner these
things go forever unless they hit a
corner yes okay so I'm going to talk
about at least to start with a problem
called an illumination problem so maybe
I have a new figure of a billiard table
maybe think of that as a room now that's
a kind of a funny shaped room but
nonetheless and I have I put a candle at
a certain point in the room that's my
kind of a light source and the question
is does that candle illuminate every
point in the room so that means that if
I have some other point in the room is
there a beam of light that will start at
the candle and start bouncing off the
walls of the room may be many many
bounces until it finally hits that point
so in other words does the candle
illuminate the entire room or are there
places in the room which are dark that
the candle doesn't illuminate the
question is moving in any direction can
you get to this point the candle is
radiating light out in all directions
and do you
every point for example of my room is
just a usual kind of a square and my
candle is anywhere in the room I can
certainly get to any other place in the
room by just going in a straight line so
I can go here's my candle here's my
other point in the room I don't have to
do any bouncing off walls because I just
go in a straight line this kind of room
is called convex which means that you
can join any two points by a line
without bouncing off the sides so convex
rooms it's obvious or clear that
illumination happens this room is not
convex because if I'm at this point
there is no straight line that gets me
from the candle to this point because
the straight line would you know leave
the room and I'm not allowed to do that
the original problem while illumination
was asked in the 1950s one question was
does every point illuminate every other
point the first example where this was
solved in a way and that was by Roger
Penrose was a English mathematician and
physicist what he did was he draws the
top half of an ellipse and he draws the
bottom half of an ellipse the same lips
but doesn't connect them and instead he
draws a mushroom and then a similar
mushroom on the other side the red point
here is the focal point of the ellipse
the top ellipse and here's the other
point is the focal point of the top
ellipse and then these points are the
focal points of the bottom ellipse and
what Penrose found was that for example
if his candle was placed right there
somewhere in the top half these two
regions were not illuminated so in other
words there was no way of sending a
light source from the candle and having
it bounce into to those two shaded
regions there permanently dark if that
is where the candle is and wedding show
was no matter where you put the candle
there will be a regions in this ellipse
which are dark that are not illuminated
by the candle
oh there's no there's no welcome put the
candidate no spot where you could put
the candle and illuminate the entire
table in 1995 a man by the name of
Piekarski
found an example of a twenty six sided
tall
and a place where you could put the
candle where it didn't illuminate some
other place on the table why is does
this have to be so complicated well if
you have a polygon as I drove here it's
sort of hard to decide when you said the
light source found where that beam of
light is going to go so this problem of
what what you illuminate is is possibly
pretty complicated and so that's why
this first example there was a point
right here with a candle he found a
single point which was not illuminated
by that candle now the difference
between this and the Penrose example was
in the Penrose example there was a
candle and there was a whole region two
of them which were not illuminated and
this example is somewhat different it
and this was kind of the only point that
wasn't illuminated you could get to any
any place in this room except if you
were standing right if you stood right
there at that point you would be in the
dark but everybody everywhere else you
would see the light from the candle so
it's a little different setup it's an
incontestable point it well it's a
single point you can think of it as
infinite ethical but it's a single point
as opposed to a whole part of the room
and your person is standing right at
that place that person is in the dark
somebody's standing right next to that
person sees is in the light so it's it's
a little it's a little different it says
it's a mathematical construction it's
not literally a person standing at a
point because after all our feets have
width and and so it's it's a it's more
of a you know theoretical construct
there has been research in just in the
last two or three years that says that
for any polygon and now I'm going to put
a little kind of restriction what I want
to look at is when the angles at the
vertex are a fraction a rational number
P over Q is a rational number times 180
degrees so every angle is a rational
number times 180 degrees for example a
square is square room that angle is 90
degrees that's of course one half of 180
I want to talk about polygons where all
of the angles are
any rational number in degrees they're
called rational polygons or rational
billiards if I put a candle at any place
the dark regions are these as you say
infinitesimal points and there are only
finitely many so maybe two of them or
something for example in the tow car ski
example there was just one point there
might be two or three or ten but there
isn't something that's a whole patch of
infinitely many points so it's
impossible to construct a rational
polygon that will have a patch of that
that's right you only ever have that's
right you will not in this example
rational polygon you will never have a
whole part of the room which is dark
that will never happen that even a small
one not even a very tiny one what is an
irrational polygon for example let me
draw an irrational triangle and I'm
going to make the angle here ninety
times the square root of two let's say
thirty degrees and then here since the
total is has to be 180 this would be 180
minus 90 square root of two minus 30
obviously professor that in convex
because it's not going to be in yeah
yeah so triangles of course are convex
thank you for that observation so but
this is an example this this is an
example of a non rational triangle if I
created a complicated polygon that had
irrational angles Genda I don't think
anything is known about the illumination
problem as far as I know the things that
are known as rational polygons so that's
the illumination problem it it really
started in 1955 and as a consequence of
other study of other things having to do
with rational billiards there's been new
work and progress on this illumination
problem I thought I would mention one
other problem that arises that you can
ask about polygons you could ask is
there what's called a periodic orbit
when I say orbit that might be started
off at a point
it's really difficult very skillful Oh
beautiful I think we're old friends
rancid resins reminding people I've got
to add